أصيب شخص واحد على الأقل بالمرض داخل
طائرة دلتا التي كانت عالقة على المدرج
هناك في ظل حرارة ثلاثية الأرقام،
وكانت درجة الحرارة في الخارج 111 درجة ولم
يكن هناك مكيف هواء في
المقصورة، يخبرنا أحد الركاب بما حدث
بعد ذلك
كان الأمر أشبه بالفوضى في  في هذه المرحلة
كانت هناك امرأة تسير في الممر،
بدت وكأنها على
وشك الإغماء، وانتهى بهم الأمر بوضع
قناع الأكسجين على الأشخاص الذين تقيأوا، وقد
أغمي عليهم، كما تعلم، ذهبوا إلى
الحمام
لكنها قالت إنها حصلت على الكثير من الناس
مريض من الحرارة بما في ذلك
طاقم الطائرة وتم إلغاء الرحلة إلى أتلانتا في
نهاية المطاف، وقد اعتذرت شركة الطيران
وأصدرت هذا البيان.
تبحث فرق دلتا في
الظروف التي أدت إلى
درجات حرارة غير مريحة داخل تلك المقصورة
وعدم الراحة هو بخس